[Music]
what up anime fans goes on here for
anime uproar and today we're actually
going to be looking at the new
promotional video for the next dragon
ball super ark and as you guys know what
you've been following a while I used to
do episode reviews with kid Kai my good
friend and we used to talk about each
other's ago we haven't been doing that
for a while but we've been still keeping
up with the show and I'm just super
psyched for this are at the last two
episodes of Dragon Ball super 75 and 76
we're awesome i love the Crillon
characterization I think it's cool how
they showed that they can make
interesting content with how actually
having the world on the line and like
the power being to the maximum extent I
feel like it was nice being Crillon
overcome his challenges and those are
obviously challenges that everyone can
relate to in some field or another so
the slice-of-life episodes have been
pretty pretty good especially the
Crillon ones i think topped the fillers
off nicely and now we're going to be
getting back to the tournament which
would be awesome i hope they keep up
being as good as the Crillon soldier who
actually really didn't like those and
maybe it's just nostalgia but i was
enjoying that and i love the fact that
Crillon buzz his hair that was awesome
so now we're just going to jump right to
it I'm going to go look at the preview
trailer we got a comment on it and yeah
let's check it out it's okay so we're
about to get started and i'm just going
to pause as we go when I see something
interesting that I want to explore let's
do it we start off with the to Zeno's
[Music]
goku hyping it up
and then we have a crazy clown here we
all know that clowns need of us
especially when they're smiling smugly
like that so I would not want to be his
opponent and this is awesome so we just
saw a female what appears to be a female
saying turn into let's see brawley so
like pretty much female brawl so that's
sick because we haven't really seen a
lot of female super sand so I think
incorporating one is awesome and what
the won't be great is if she'd be Vegeta
that was w Krillin again I hope with
Crillon that they make it good they
incorporate strategy he's overcome his
fears right so we don't have to keep on
going with that shinji complex just you
know being unsure of himself can't react
so he's overcome that in the cellar
which is awesome and I can't wait to see
how they'll battle I hope that they do
them justice I hope he does some
strategic plans at least where's your
point down it's not completely to teach
them and we have Vegeta here and if you
look here this wolf design actually
looks awesome this guy go blue is
fighting I mean this was probably one of
the coolest designs I've seen enjoying
Ball super I love wolves like this guy
the scarf I think keys is a badass it's
going to be fun watching that
[Music]
so that's the guys I can't wait now let
me know in the comments below if you're
excited for the universe's tournament
arc I can't wait personally and I'll be
trying to do weekly episode reviews for
joining Ball super I like to have at
least one show during the season i'm
following weekly so look out for that
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]